Ich bin der zuständige Arzt.
Ich würde gerne mit Ihnen das Aufnahmegespräch führen, aber damit ich beginne, würde ich Ihre
Person nicht Informationen bieten.
Sind Sie damit verstanden?
Wenn es nicht zu persönlich wird, erzähle ich Ihnen gerne etwas.
Ja.
Wie heißen Sie denn?
Ich heiße Natalia Cremon.
Könnten Sie bitte Ihre Vor- und Nachname bestabieren?
Ja, Natalia N-A-T-A-L-I-A, Natalia.
Ja.
Und dann Cremor-K-R-E, also A-Umlaut, M-E-R.
Frau Cremor, wie alt sind Sie?
Genau.
Ich bin 76 Jahre.
76.
Und wann wurden Sie genau geboren?
Am 4.8. 1949.
Und wie groß sind Sie?
1.68, weiß ich zumindest mal.
1.68.
Und wie viel wiegen Sie?
Ich wiege so um die 80 Kilo.
Gut.
Frau Cremor, lassen Sie uns über Ihre Beschwerde sprechen.
Wie kann ich Ihnen helfen?
Was für Sie so uns?
Ich habe eigentlich solch ein heftiges Schmerz.
Das ist schon seit Tagen, dass es so im Rücken und an der Seite wehtut,
auf der linken Seite.
Und das strahlt in den Bauch rein.
Und es zieht und sticht.
Und tatsächlich habe ich auch, wenn ich auf die Toilette gehe,
ganz heftige Schmerzen.
Und ich muss ständig auf die Toilette.
Ich denke, ich trink gar nicht so viel, aber ich habe ständig das Gefühl,
dass ich auf die Toilette muss.
Und dann kommt gar nicht viel, aber das tut dann so weh,
das brennt ganz tüchtig und ist ganz schmerzhaft.
Und ja, da habe ich mir, da stimmt irgendwas nicht.
Und deswegen habe ich gedacht, ich muss mal dringend zu Ihnen kommen.
Und diese Rückenschmerzen, das drückt und sticht,
das ist sehr, sehr gemein.
Okay.
Wie stark sind die Schmerzen auf einer Schmerzskala von 0 bis 10,
wobei 0 keine Schmerzen, 10 am Start des Schmerzen bedeutet?
Schwer zu sagen.
Also, das sind schon sehr, sehr heftige Schmerzen.
Also, ich werde die gerne los.
Ah, sagen wir so zwischen 6 und 7 oder so?
6 und 7.
Und ja, möchten Sie Medikamente ein oder könnten Sie bis zum Ende des Gesprächs aushalten?
Ja, Schmerzmittel helfen ja gar nicht.
Ich habe schon, ich habe etwas genommen,
so was ich zu Hause hatte, Ibuprofen,
aber das hat eigentlich überhaupt nicht geholfen.
Und insofern, ja, ich meine, jetzt bis ja nicht so lange dauern das Gespräch.
Wie viel Milligramm Ibuprofen?
Wo ich weiß gar nicht, was da auf der Packung drauf steht.
Ich habe die immer zu Hause liegen, wenn ich mal Schmerzen habe.
Weiß ich aber nicht, was da drin ist.
Okay.
Und haben Sie einige, welche haben Sie gehabt?
Wie? Ob ich das früher schon mal hatte?
Ja, Rückenschmerzen.
Rückenschmerzen hat man natürlich immer mal, aber nicht solche.
Nee, also das fühlt sich schon anders an.
Ja klar, wenn ich mal zu viel gearbeitet habe, oder so,
dann, ja, dann habe ich das schon mal Rückenschmerzen, aber nicht solche.
Nee, nee, nee, das ist anders.
Okay. Gibt es etwas, das die Schmerzen lindert oder verstärkt?
Ja, ich hatte das Gefühl, wenn ich im Bett lach,
dass es dann ein bisschen besser war.
Und ich habe mir dann auch eine Wärmflasche gemacht,
aber jetzt bei den Temperaturen mag man auch keine Wärmflasche haben.
Und das war dann auch nicht so gut.
Und, aber beim Liegen war es besser, als wenn ich rumlaufe, ja.
Aber ich muss halt ständig aufstehen,
auch weil ich alle Stunde wenigstens, wenn ich häufiger auf die Toilette muss.
Ja.
Und Frau Kremmert, treten die Schmerzen anfassartig auf
oder sind sie dauerhaft da?
Ja, die sind eigentlich schon ständig da,
aber, aber, aber so diese Schmerzen,
wenn ich auf der Toilette bin, vor allen Dingen, wenn es dann zu Ende ist,
ja, wenn, ah, diese Schmerzen, die, die sind natürlich immer nur in der Situation da.
Und treten die Schmerzen blössig oder allmähnlich auf?
Ja, mit allem, ich habe das gemerkt, dass es langsam angefangen hat
und dann ist es immer schlimmer geworden.
Slimmer geworden, okay.
Haben Sie Fieber?
Ja, ich habe nicht gemessen, aber ich habe tatsächlich,
in der letzten Nacht habe ich, habe ich so geschwitzt
und dann habe ich gefroren mit einmal, das war ganz merkwürdig.
Und schlecht ist mir vor Schmerzen, ja.
Ja, wie ist die Rapatiz?
Ja, zurzeit schmeckt es mir gar nicht,
vorher habe ich eigentlich immer gerne gegessen,
aber muss halt ein bisschen aufpassen,
weil ich so ein Alterszucker habe, da darf ich halt nicht so essen,
wie ich gerne möchte, aber grundsätzlich schmeckt es mir eigentlich schon gut, ja.
Okay, das ist gut.
Und leiden Sie unter Übelkreiz?
Unter was?
Übelkreiz.
Ja, also schlecht ist mir schon, schlecht ist mir schon vor Schmerzen einfach, ja.
Und haben Sie erbrochen?
Nein, nein, nein, so ist es nicht, nicht,
dass mir so vom Magen schlecht ist, sondern eigentlich so,
dass mich das so beeinträchtigt, dass ich mich so schlappfühle, ja.
Und haben Sie Probleme mit dem Stuhlgang oder beim Wasserlassen?
Ja, beim Wasserlassen habe ich ja gerade gesagt,
und wie, was ich da für Probleme habe, ja.
Und beim Stuhlgang, ja, also normalerweise, ja,
das alles klappt ganz gut, aber manchmal bin ich ein bisschen verstopft,
dann muss ich halt mal so ein pflanzliches Präparat nehmen,
was ich mir in der Apotheke hole, ja.
Und haben Sie Blut im Handrang bemerkt?
Wo habe ich Blut bemerkt?
Im Handrang.
Im Handrang?
Im Urin, ja.
Im Urin?
Also Blut, ich habe da nichts Rotes gesehen,
also mir ist schon aufgefallen, dass das ein bisschen unangenehm riecht
und das Dunkle ist als normalerweise.
Dunkle.
Aber da kommt ja auch fast nichts, da sind immer nur so ein paar Tropfen
und dann tut es weh und dann ist schon wieder vorbei, ja.
Und schlafen Sie gut?
Nein, zurzeit natürlich nicht, aber normalerweise,
ja, also geht so, würde ich sagen, ja.
In meinem Alter schläft man nicht mehr so gut.
Und Frau Krömer, ich habe vergessen, seit wann haben Sie diese Schmerz?
Also eigentlich hat das so vor zwei, drei Tagen angefangen, ja.
Aber erst war das nicht so schlimm,
dann habe ich auch gedacht, ja, wenn ich ein bisschen mehr trinke,
dann wird es vielleicht besser, aber es ist gar nicht besser geworden.
Okay.
Und ja, bekommen Sie Ihre Monatswunutung regelmäßig?
Ja, hören Sie mal, wie alt ich bin, da hat man keine Monatsblutung mehr,
ich bin schon 20 Jahre in der Menopause.
Und besseren Sie Ihre Frauenarzt regelmäßig?
Ja, so zur Krebsvorsorge gehe ich vorhin, ja, ja, klar.
Okay, das ist gut.
Und haben Sie eine chronische Erkrankung, wie zum Beispiel Bluthochdrück oder Blutzucker?
Da habe ich Ihnen ja gesagt, dass ich so zuckerkrank bin, Alterszucker, ne?
Und ja, das habe ich jetzt auch schon ein paar Jahre,
fast 20 Jahre, würde ich sagen, ja.
Und ja, ein bisschen hohen Blutdruck habe ich natürlich auch, ja,
das, ja, was alle haben halt, ne?
Und nehmen Sie dagegen Medikamente ein?
Ja, natürlich, ich nehme mit Formin regelmäßig, ja schon, das ist ja klar, seit 20 Jahren.
Und dann gegen den Blutdruck bekomme ich so eine Tablette,
denn es ist aber gar nicht viel, das ist irgendwie so eine Tablette morgens,
das ist Ramipril.
Ramipril.
Und wie viel Minigram mit Formin und Ramipril?
Also mit Formin, das ist eine Tausende, da nehme ich morgens und abends eine.
Und Ramipril 5, da nehme ich eine morgens.
Einmal morgens.
Okay.
Ist Ihre Blutdrück und Blutzucker in Ordnung?
Ja, so hin und wieder gehe ich zu meinem Hausarzt und kontrolliere das, aber
ich war das jetzt in letzter Zeit immer so ganz gut.
Okay, sind Sie alle against gegen etwas?
Ja, ich kann nicht so gut so Hausstaub haben.
Ich muss immer aufpassen mit Teppichbüden und mit alten Bettecken oder so was.
Das muss ich immer alles schön ausschütteln, also so eine Hausstauballegie habe ich.
Das muss ich halt furchtbar niesen und manchmal trennen, auch die Augen wenn es schlimm ist,
aber also das ist nicht so ganz schlimm.
Okay, haben Sie einen Oberträglichkeit?
Ja, Hausstaub halt.
Ja, okay.
Und rauchen Sie?
Ich rauche, ja, ja, ja, aber ich habe nie so richtig viel geraucht.
Immer nur so halbe Packung am Tag oder so, aber nie so richtig doll viel.
Seit wann haben Sie geraucht?
Oh Gott, seit ich 16 bin, wenn ich ehrlich bin.
16, seit 16 Jahren.
Seit 50 Jahren. Seit ich 16 bin, jetzt bin ich 76.
Okay, trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, also eine Flasche Bier zum Abend trinke ich gerne mal oder auch mein Glas Wein.
Mein Glas Wein.
Und Frau Prämmer, bitte nehmen Sie nicht beispielsweise, das ist eine Routinefrage,
nehmen Sie Drogen.
Also Drogen außer meinen Tabletten nehme ich keine weiteren Drogen ein, nee, nee.
Okay, das ist gut.
Und sind Sie schon einmal operiert worden?
Ja, so als Kind, was man da so an üblichen Operationen hat, ja,
der Winter rauskommt und die Mandeln sind rausgekommen,
das Kind war ja.
Und wie alt waren Sie, als Sie operiert wurden?
Also ich war gerade in der weiterführenden Schule, also mit 11 so was muss das gewesen sein.
Und dann mit dem Blindarm, das war ein paar Jahre später, vielleicht so mit 14, 15.
Okay, leben Ihre Eltern noch?
Nee, meine Eltern leben schon lange nicht mehr.
Meinerseits war es, woher Sie gestorben sind?
Woher Sie gestorben sind, das weiß man immer nicht so genau,
weil meine Mutter, wie hieß es, die hätte ein Herz in Farb gehabt,
weil mein Vater, der war halt dann auch irgendwann alt
und hatte viele Erkrankungen, der hatte auch Zuckerbrankheit,
der hatte auch hohen Blutdruck und der hatte auch außerdem ordentlich mit Räumen zu tun,
da hatte auch immer viel Medikamente genommen, da war es halt irgendwann zu viel.
Ja, Frau Bremer, könnten Sie wiederholen bitte, meine WhatsApp gelingelt?
Ich kann nicht gehört sein.
Ja, also ich wollte wissen, was meine Eltern hatten, woran die gestorben sind.
Ja.
Und meine Mutter, das weiß ich, die hat den Herz in Farb gehabt.
Und mein Vater, woran, was dann tatsächlich ursächlich war, warum der gestorben ist,
der hatte halt viele Krankheiten, der hatte Rheuma
und hatte auch viele Medikamente genommen, weil das eben Schmerzen gemacht hat.
Und dann hatte der auch diesen Alterszucker genau, wie ich das habe
und hatte auch hohen Blutdruck, das weiß ich.
Hey, das tut mir leid.
Und haben Sie Geschwister?
Ja, zwei Brüder habe ich.
Ja.
Haben Sie eine Erkrankung?
Ja, bei dem einen weiß ich, dass er auch Blutdruck hat
und der andere muss genauso wie ich auch mit Formin nehmen.
Der hat also auch diesen Alterszucker.
Der ist auch ein bisschen dicker als der andere, ja.
Ja.
Sind Sie verreiratet?
Ich bin verwittwitt schon viele Jahre.
Können Sie sie wiederholen bitte?
Ich bin verwittwitt seit vielen Jahren.
Und haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, aber die Kinder sind natürlich längst aus dem Haus,
die sind alle erwachsen, ja.
Okay, sind Sie gesund?
Sind Ihre Kinder gesund?
Ja, ja, davon gehe ich aus.
Ja, sie haben jetzt keine schwerwiegenden Erkrankungen.
Dreid, wenn Sie Sport?
Ja, Sie werden sich wundern.
Ich gehe gerne zum Square Dance.
Das geht auch im hohen Alter noch.
Nicht mehr so doll wie früher,
aber hin und wieder gehe ich da gerne hin, ja.
Was machen Sie beruflich?
Ich bin natürlich in Rente.
Sind Sie vollständig geimpft?
Sie meinen da diese Corona-Impfung?
Ja, ja, die habe ich damals alle machen lassen.
Ja, das hat man den alten Leuten empfohlen.
Und Frau Kremer, das waren meine Fragen.
Ich denke, ich habe alle wichtige Informationen gesammelt.
Nach der Mangaben denke ich, Steine in Nieren.
Aber das ist nur ein Verdacht.
Und durch weitere Untersuchungen werden bestätigt.
Jetzt würde ich eine körperliche Untersuchung durchführen
und Vitalparameter messen.
Was bedeutet das Vitalparameter messen?
Vitalparameter bedeutet Ihre Herzfrequenz, Ihre Fibre,
Ihre Sauerstoffsetigung,
eine Messung von Sauerstoffsetigung,
Ihre Blutdruck.
Blutdruck, das ist natürlich immer gut, wenn man nachguckt.
Der ist ja auch sonst ein bisschen wackelig.
Gut, und dann?
Und anschließend würde ich etwas Blut abnehmen,
um Laboschämischen Untersuchungen zu bestimmen.
Und gegenseitig würde ich den Bauch anordnen.
Das ist ja mehr der Rücken, wo es wehtut.
Ja, aber den Bauchschall hilft uns,
sich in der Organe zu machen.
Und gegebenenfalls würde ich die Kompetentomographie anfertigen.
Ja, das haben Sie Fragen?
Nein, das wird schon alles eine Richtigkeit haben.
Okay, dann soll ich noch ins Wartezimmer gehen?
Ja, Sie sollen im Wartezimmer warten.
Dann warte ich jetzt noch ein bisschen mich aufrufen.
Okay, gut.
Ich kann das nicht ganz zu Ende lesen, auf den Blick.
Nicht vollständig entleeren können.
Das eigentlich eher nicht.
Ich habe eher das Gefühl, dass ich Ihnen richtig halten kann.
Das ist ständig Pübimacher noch.
Gibt es noch andere Fragen?
Hallo, guten Tag Frau Oberarzt.
Ich bin der neue Assistenzart und möchte Ihnen eine neue Patientin
in der Notaufnahme vorstellen.
Nun stelle ich meine Patientin vor.
Es handelt sich um Frau Natalia Crema,
ein 56-jähriger Patientin gebogen am 14,
18, 1908, nein, 1970.
Wenn 69, ja. Aber sie hat ja tatsächlich gesagt, sie ist 49 geboren.
Das erklärt auch einige Ihrer Fragen.
Warum Sie nicht gemerkt haben, dass das eine alte Frau war?
76 Jahre ist sie alt.
Sie ist 1 Meter 68 groß und wiegt aktuell 80 kg.
Sie stelle sich heute seit zwei Tagen bestehenden,
langsam auftretenen, progradierenden,
persisterenden Rückenschmerzen.
Die Schmerzen strahlen in den Bauch aus.
Sie schreit die Schmerzen als drückend und strehend.
Wo sind die Schmerzen genau lokalisiert im Rücken?
Sie stäuft die Schmerzen auf einer Schmerzskala.
Ich möchte wissen, wo die Schmerzen genau lokalisiert sind.
Rückend, linke Seite.
Okay, wie kann man dazu noch sagen?
Da kommt das Stichwort Flanke.
Die Schmerzen auf einer Schmerzskala mit 6 bis 7 von 10.
Die Frage nach Linderungsfaktor wurde mit Ligen und Betlage bejaht.
Die Frage nach Ähnliches beschwerden wurde bei 9.
Nach vorherigen Beschwerden.
Sie berichtete, dass sie unter die Syri und Polarkisuri leidet.
Die vegetative Anamnese auffällig mit Öbelkeit.
Die Frage nach Schlafstörung und Fieber wurde verneint.
Was ist denn auffällig an der vegetativen Anamnese?
Öbelkeit, aber jedoch keine Erbrechen.
Die Frage nach Insomnia und Inapatit wurde verneint.
Sie hat mitgeteilt, dass sie im Urin Blut bemerkt.
Sie klare über dunkle Urin.
Sie klare über Verstoffung.
Sie hat Ibuprofen angenommen, aber das hat nicht geholfen.
Sie hat Arterielle Hypertonie und Diabetes.
Das ist vor Erkrankungen.
Sie hat mitgeteilt, dass sie mit 1000 mg abends und 5 mg abends.
Sie wurde als Kind operiert.
Sie ist als Kind operiert?
Ja, als sie 11 Jahre war, sind sie transylektor.
Als sie 14 oder 15 Jahre alt war, ist sie appendectomy operiert worden.
Sie ist allergisch gegen Hausstau.
Es ausatzt sich trennende Augen.
Sie raucht seit 15 Jahren Halbpackung.
Macht wie viel Packiers?
Sie trinkt täglich ein Fläschbier und ein Glas Wein.
Sie hat schon einmal keine Drucken und hat ihre Vater Arterielle Hypertonie.
Sie ist gestorben.
Sie hat zwei Brüder.
Was machen Sie mit der Patientin?
Sie hat drei Brüder.
Sie hat zwei Brüder.
Wir sehen uns am Dienstag.